about Pope Francis
Well, yes, he has been saying for a long time in
his public statements that
he is ready to provide his services,
the same general positions periodically
spoke and President Macron even Chancellor
Scholz said that he would continue to
talk with Putin, of course, Pope
Francisco and calls for negotiations, but he
did Here  recently, some very
incomprehensible statement
is not at all Christian,
singling out
two nationalities of the Russian Federation
into some category from which atrocities can be
expected during
hostilities, we reacted to this, our
Ministry and
Buryatia reacted and the Chechen
Republic The Vatican said that they
hope this is no longer
such a misunderstanding will be repeated Well, of course,
this case does not help And the authority of the Holy See does not
need the China Sea is now becoming
one of those regions where NATO is not
averse, as they once did in
Ukraine, they are not averse to escalating tension,
we know how serious the
Chinese  th people's republic relates to
such provocations. Not to mention
Taiwan, the Taiwan Strait, and we
understand that
such NATO games with fire in those
parts. They carry threats and risks for the
Russian Federation.
NATO, led by the United
States, perfectly understands that they wanted to
draw India into an anti
-Chinese anti-Russian alliance.  indie refused to
join any structures
that would have the nature of a
military-political bloc, it
only participates in economic projects that are being
promoted in the context of these
endo-pacific strategies